hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to soma don't anger
over apparently hello why is it glowing
eyes their glow what is that is that a
WoW is that a whoa creature are we still
going down oh hey hey buddies
how you doing I know what I'm supposed
to do now
this is not what I was expecting I was
expecting everything to go horrible all
at once can i oh I can get up now oh I
can move flags too big dumb dummy do can
I not pop that out ah time to go up tap
and see what's our matter apparently I'm
in the middle of nowhere
pray for the deep dark abyss oh okay
well sure nothing a battle happened
while I'm trying to fix this this is
another puzzle hey why don't we stop
moving the power blacked out for a
moment
think you could be the atmospheric
pressure is pushing pretty hard really
testing the limits press shoot how do
you know that it hold comforting it
should baby you know could be I got a
press button what do I gotta do oh I
gotta sit back down that's why go keep
your arms and hands this time freeze
when you're not powered
what's the difference I don't feel like
I'm being held back or hindered and I
don't have the opportunity to reflect on
the time I'm missing it's simply missing
sounds like sleeping without dreaming
yes but generally you anticipate when
you're about to sleep and there's a
natural continuation since we tend to
wake up where we went to sleep my
experience is more like an ever-changing
moment that never really seems to find
closure sounds kind of like a movie
being edited line I suppose so
I guess it sounds exciting but it really
keeps me activated to the point of
exhaustion rush could be worse could be
a time traveler stuck in a body made
from black poop I'll be the worst hey
why is the image showing a very broken
thing are we there yet
good gosh darn gang oh oh hey oh hey oh
hey whoa oh
what are you what did I done is that
Ross oh boy
what are we got going on now good you're
back
what happened something dropped up to
the cage that's you right out um spoke
to me yeah but but then what a WoW
features it just stared if you for a
moment then threw himself down the abyss
said it would make preparations
I don't like the sound of that it was
very strange I thought it was gonna kill
you for sure glad it didn't yeah me too
looks like we're closing in on the ocean
floor good not sure the climbers have
taken much longer okay so this is the
Omega sector it's about an acre of the
abyssal plan used by pathos to I expect
let's do some walking before we reach
town
yeah been here before not in a way that
will help us right idealogy has been
here we're following in your old
footsteps cap when it has footsteps you
could still be down here somewhere
let's head for toe inside that art okay
let's get it buckaroo I can't wait to
see we're really not gonna worry more
about that weird creature that came
after me I mean I imagine that's not
necessarily the whoa but if it's not
then what is it hello Oh what
interesting creatures down here on the
ocean floor I wonder when they'll break
into song and tell me about how great I
am and the love that I'm gonna find in
my life I already found plenty of love
oh gee dokey that what do we got danger
area unsafe stay close to the lights no
joke I hear the ominous death
approaching from all directions oh woe
is me wandering alone in this abyss I am
cursed with my existence except I got an
exact copy of me right upstairs
hello what do we got signed in sample
collections physical pickup checked our
vacua ssin failed bring the ark to fie
Alec Waldo okay well I can't sign in why
would that be blending huh run the
bottom of the ocean why would there be
lightning let me know I'm not very smart
in the sciences but I'm pretty sure they
know lightning got down down here hmm
also I got to stay the lights or else
I'll die a horrible horrible death not
that I'm not tempted to explore the
darkness and see what kind of horrible
horrible death awaits me but frankly I'd
rather not die a horrible horrible death
oh come in Tao please answer Tao nothing
it's dead let's move out
we'll try the next one
okey-dokey then well apparently
everything went to [ __ ] so how do I stay
in the lights when there go Jill oh fish
that seems scary that's like my again
why are there there be lightning some
done that up here
something seems little bizarre I don't
know nothing about much but I know this
ain't right
mm II know him I got a bad feeling about
this
hmm hello anything in here that I need
anything important in here no gosh darn
it huh nope okay so
seriously the hell is that I'm sure it
will be addressed in time hello
we got warning fault line activities oh
it's not an earthquake
ittsan it's not lightning it's an
earthquake
nevermind my joke got ruined everything
else stupid stupid can't even say jokes
right some stupid
all right we get up here alright fault
line or not I know the difference
between an earthquake and a lightning
strike this is [ __ ] Oh it's
someone's head what the hell stick to
the lamp place they won't go near them I
can't fell Glasson it's important I
reach mama Kron future depends on it
calm down let's just follow the path if
I die I need you to tell Julia doll that
the while he's out of control she needs
to get nasarah
he'll know what to do Raj you can tell
him yourself we just need to pick up the
pace okay class Foster Park I need to go
back I know where to go come on the
lines over there final push for us
almost there we just
well good to know that it introduced the
concept to my impending death just
beyond the darkness
goody goody gumdrops oh boy cut chunk
stay close blue leads to Tao red leads
to the climber okey-dokey then why does
Tao have a halo over it here we go
Oh death awaits me death is coming
better charming does is coming blue to
Tao blue to Tao that's really cool there
red on the back nice good concept well
thought it well thought out Oh
death is looming over my head
yeah okay alright then we're gonna
ignore that there's a whole lot of
nothing going on what is spattering into
my windshield
is it seem like there's an underwater
thunderstorm happening something's a
little fishy er close the door so that
the draught doesn't get in alright oh
crap
well that ain't good why'd that happen
put it back
what am I in pull it again okay alright
guess I'm on my own
what do we got what're that what ad i
press inventory artificial lure dried
squid they got pretty much nothing but a
lot of artificial lures observation
dried squid sixty pieces of anima Felix
shark oh there's more okay
circle around eat dry squid mantle size
of a man
angler fish disfigured by the gel our
mannequin will attack anything still
hard to turn whoa has affected their
behavior huh oh crap come on humpback
whale population size
I don't need there's there's no legend
here I don't know what these graphs mean
okay again don't know what the graphs
mean you're inferring a lot at like
missing out on a lot of data but there's
a star cries and something towards the
end what else we got
hello I'll take some of you good to know
this still works the same already then
okie-dokie
so yeah I guess there's nothing else for
me here I mean this kind of seems like
it needs to happen but I really have no
idea what else okay I'm assuming that I
got everything out of here crap oh that
does not look good
how am I supposed to get to places
without being eviscerated oh I just need
a sack uh I guess I fell out so here's
the sacking up I'm gonna die I'm gonna
die I'm gonna die oh lordy daddy I'm
gonna die I see lights over there but
I'm gonna die oh I'm gonna die oh I'm
gonna die okay I think I'm good
maybe still feel like I'm gonna die
still feel
is it just me or do you guys also see
shapes in the darkness I see figures
things blowing not glowing but I mean
like outlines and shadows maybe it's
just me am I supposed to go in here this
is - oh god oh oh that's why I went in
here
I did not know the death was that close
I had a sneaking suspicion oh boy and
some strong gusts of wind where am I
going
Hisense death there we go I guess I was
fine except for the things alrighty then
okay here we go
trick
Hey
ooh boy okay we're fine we're fine
oh we're not fine are we oh we're not
fine oh we're not fine
oh we're not fine oh I know what that
was
are we fine am i panicking over nothing
I'm being a damned coward again and
loading and I think we're good okay all
right that was easier than I thought
okay so there's an electrical
disturbance in here insufficient power
you say oh hello how can you use this
anyone there
this is Tao who is this this is Ian
Peterson of theta calling I got a team
with me and we're about half a kilometer
from Tao what how did you came in the
climber listen we're having a really
hard time with this sector heavy
turbulence is making it difficult to
move forward and the wildlife you got is
absolutely rabid the storm comes and
goes the instruments show the weather is
relatively fair right now you should
move out as soon as possible
stick to the lights the critters should
leave you alone all right you heard the
man
we're moving out people down keep the
doors unlock we're coming in
something tells me that they didn't make
it to their destination I'm still a
little confused about the entire layout
of pathos - then again maybe I'm not
supposed to understand it all all right
here we go
okay I still wonder if I'm gonna see the
done bat anytime soon the rogue rampant
rampaging gun bet can I please thank you
who is that bubble butt no that's not
bubble butt
ah damn it was close so must be a
deep-sea version of bubble butt I'll
still be your friend I don't care if you
are a deep-sea version of bubble butt
I need a friend cuz at this point I
really don't have a friend hello hi Oh
your big bubble butt oh you're a big a
bubble butt you got big bubbles coming
out of here but I like you
I'm gonna call you biggie bubbles bubble
biggie biggie bubble bubble biggie
that's your name baby bubble bubble
biggie you want to come over this way
come on baby bubble bubble biggie
control well that's bad sounds
observatory is your landing town go to
town meet bubble bubble baby blue baby
bubble bubble baby coos biggie bubble BB
BB go go BB save me save me oh my god
baby oh baby don't let me die oh baby
please I'm following your lie baby
you're my guiding light in the stove
crap
maybe maybe you would leave here you own
baby baby baby baby no baby no baby baby
huh crazy baby whoa hey baby what are
you doing baby baby where are you going
baby what are you doing baby
bebe okay
alright then all those sounds are
comforting oh it's lovely when I go down
to the bottom eosin hear the screams of
the Damned thanks PO today so much
brighter I know baby I know
this [ __ ] is hooked yes baby I know
mobile but is kind of upsetting me at
this moment but you know whoa what is
that
I thought I saw it like a line or
something yeah bubble but ain't too
happy with me are you our friend right
baby piggy bubble bubble-butt baby
bubble bubble bee bee bee bee
PT's good enough nothing else to say
baby you know girl that way we can build
a relationship and to move
baby I'm coming for you baby I'm gonna
save you I'm coming to get you baby baby
don't
oh no not baby oh baby
well I make friends and they immediately
take them away oh my god oh oh oh oh God
oh look eenie meenie I see any light oh
I go this way oh hey what is this
Oh God another goopy poor baby take away
my friends bubble butts anatomy and up
be bees dead
Oh
I'm just gonna assume that these caves
were carved out by the creature and
aren't really here for my benefit god
you weird finger bone spiders ah they
really did pick the most grotesque thing
they could think of Oh everywhere -
reminds me of the monsters from the
original penumbra that he actually had
to fight with like clunky movement
frictional games come a long way since
then baby oh you're not baby whoa what
the frickin Freaker foot new new wells
geez
that's some [ __ ] right there that's
some [ __ ]
as soon Boal who is with its face what
was with this horrible face what was I
supposed to do run back into the cave I
really think it was BB they did that
intentionally I should have known there
was no way the BB could have still been
alive
all right
anyway
oh hey how's it going hey buddy are you
in pal figment of my imagination
okey-dokey then
I seriously think they made the cloud
specifically to look like there's
humanoid figures in the darkness and the
little shadowy spots in between them
that's really what it looks like like
I'm not crazy you guys seeing this too
right I'm not crazy
well I might be crazy but I you guys
still see this right probably I am kind
of curious to see how I would die if I
stepped off the dark path but I'm not
that tempted
oh it's getting more wowie it's a lot of
whoa I mean it seems like they had
plenty of structure gel as it is unless
this particular structure gel that I
have is bad for the whoa geez yes please
it's about damn time thank you
I made it no one else did I didn't even
find any other bodies not that I looked
very hard
looks almost clean and nice okay here we
go
okay I mean this town the last one
something tells me that Tao actually is
the end of the road but maybe not I mean
it does have a frickin halo over it
that's not symbolic I don't know what it
is there was a bit of lag
okay then have you to be inside oh yeah
I'm not too sure about that maybe you
want to hold on your happiness a little
longer dive room oh boy oh boy am I
gonna have to copy myself again ladies
welcome to town what's left of it
you guys all right what happened here we
ran out of real food long ago people
have been getting sick haven't heard
from anyone in months
no [ __ ] they all think you're dead down
here some failed evac stories
circulating at Omicron oh god this is
something we're on an important mission
and we need your help to operate the
Omega space gun when it's done we can
all head back up the plateau but now we
need to get moving of course head on
through to the habitat we shut out the
front section of reserve power alright
see you soon
man why would they even set up a base
why would they have the gun down here
like that makes the least sense you'd
think they'd have it a little closer -
why was that all spooky
okay oh I guess this isn't a copy place
is just where one of the suits were and
there was a jail situation going on okay
good to know
see suit status yep number three is
active yeah see so the last one sub bow
oh god wait okay so suit three was
operated by the wow dude
and then Yoshida so that doesn't make
much sense where is it
oh wait back in Omicron back in the
climber station does that make any sense
obviously I'm in one suits but there's
one active at TAO weird okay that should
probably spook me but I'm Way too brave
to be spooked by the lake's of n but
seriously why I have a base all the way
down here
all right what am i doing what's
happening
who's pressurizing one now why
someone coming in
okay
what do we got here another bot okay
something ain't right here something
very now right something very uncorrect
is this where someone was coming in the
airlock that doesn't make sense because
it just came down this hallway what time
like the present oh come on
they do not mess around when it comes to
[ __ ]
this is mistake oh that was a mistake
who's this closet okay I'm gonna go
where to go
Hey
okay well that was a little wet hi I
don't hey wait
better open that up get that started
come on okay all right then well things
are a little strange
what is this
whoa pattern replicated in structure gel
poison the imprint sterilize both feed
the heart force while to kill itself
yeah
what that ain't good oh that ain't good
Oh I'm trapped in here oh that ain't
good Oh how's it going oh I'm dead I'm
so dead oh I'm so dead
Oh Oh what do you do oh you're in a suit
oh you're weird oh why you gotta be so
weird take one of these to the face well
I got more where that came from buddy I
got a chair who's your name on it you
squiggly [ __ ] oh god I can't lift it
I'm really weak sorry two dimension out
wimpy I was oh stop lollygagging oh
you're so weird with your Wibbly walk
what do you want to be my friend or
something yeah go screw yourself go
screw yourself how abouts Griesa I'm
gonna go this way now
Oh God ooh where does this go whatever
this goes I don't know what I'm doing
that big thing wants in
okay did I miss out on some stuff am I
not gonna get back there
am I not this seems like a one-way trip
alright I don't know if I miss something
I feel like I did I didn't exactly have
a choice but I feel like I missed
something what what happened okay that
voice sounded familiar I think I've
heard that voice on the radio okay so
that's all the time after this episode
thank you everybody so much for watching
check the annotation for more of the
games that I played in the past and as
always I will see you in the next video
no no no no don't go playing escape beta
everyone trust their bodies upon me
everybody oh I'm gonna pop